هذه يرجح وزير الخارجيه فنلندا بكريستو ان
يكون هناك توقف لنحو اسبوعين في محادثات
انضمام للحلف بين السويد وفنلندا وتركيا
واكد الحاجه الى ما سماه وقتا مستقطعا في
المحادثات مع تركيا بشان انضمام البلدين
لحلف شمال الاطلس ايضا الاتفاق مع تركيا
على استمرار التواصل كما كان في السابق
وانه تحدث مع نظيره التركي وان الوضع
محموم في تركيا بسبب الانتخابه
جانبها اعتبره الولايات المتحده ان حرق
ناشط يمنيه متطرف نسخه من المصحف في
السويد ربما يكون استهدافا لوحده الصف
داخل حلف شمال الاطلسي وقد ريدبريس
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه انه حار
ان حلقه كتب تعد مقدسه للكثيرين هو عمل
مهين للغايه وبغيض ومثير للشمزاز حسب
تعبيره ودافع برايس عن موقف السويد قائلا
انها تدعم حريه التجمع وان الفعل قد يكون
قانونيا ومشينا في ان وفق قوله طبربس ان
حرق المصحف كان عملا عمل شخص يهدف الى
الاستفزاز وربما عمدا الى تباعد حالفين
مقربين او التاثير على المناقشات الجاريه
بشان السويد وفي لندى الى حل في شمال
الاطلسيه
في المقابل انتقد الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسيه موقف الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ردا على ما اقدم عليه متطرف يمني
في السوق
الحادثه بعبارات شديده الوضوح
عن معارضتهم
الذي وقع في شوارع السكر
الى الحلف بعدما قطعت كل هذه المسافه
واشار الى انه على اتصال وثيق في كل
الاطرش
ميجاتي رفض وزير الخارجيه السويديه تضيي
الصعب الاستروم التعليق في الوقت الراهن
على تصريحات الرئيس التركي قال ان السويد
ستحترم الاتفاق القائمه بين السويد
وفنلندا وتركيا بشان طلب الانضمام حيث في
شمال الاطلسي حسبما نقلته وكاله الانباء
السويديه
معنى من انقره مراسلتنا فرح الزمان شوقي
فرح بناء على تصريح الرئيس اردوغان امس ما
هو التوجه الان توجه انقره بخصوص
الى نيتوسيه ما بعد حادثه احراق نسخه من
المصحف الشريف في السويد
مريم على ما يبدو ان التصعيد هو سيد
الموقف في هذه المرحله دعيني هنا ابدا من
اخر التطورات التي قد تجر هذه المشكله من
مشكله بين تركيا والسويد من جهه الى اخرى
مع دول ثانيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي استدعت
الخارجيه التركيه السفير الهولندي لديها
اليوم لتدين حادثه اخرى للاعتداء على
هاي ومعتبره بان ذلك جرائم كراهيه ولكن
بالعوده الى تصريح الرئيس التركي يبدو
واضحا بان انقره تستخدم
لهجه عاليه المستوى في هذه المرحله
فالرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يقول بانه على
ستوكل الا تتوقع ان توافق تركيا على مساله
انضمامها الى
ناته ياتي هذا بعد مباحثات طويله وبعد
الحديث عن شروط معقده هي في دقيقه همم
مريم الرئيس التركي يعتبر هنا بان الغرب
يتبع معايير مزدوجه لذلك نحن بدانا نتحدث
هنا عما يشبه الازمه الدبلوماسيه ففي
التوقيت هذا الامر حرق المصحف واعتراض
تركيا على ذلك ياتي خلال مرحله حساسه
للغايه يتقاطع فيها الرئيس التركي في
تصريحاته السياسيه مع مسؤولين اخرين من
قبيل وزير الدفاع وزير الخارجيه وكلهم
يتحدثون هنا عن ان البرلمان التركي لن
يمرر مساله الموافقه على انضمام هذين
البلدين الى النيته لان الامر لا يتعلق
فقط بالمساله الاعتداء على القران او
المصحف وهي حوادث مكرره وتريد تركيا خطوات
جديه في هذا السياق ولكن ايضا يتعلق في
بخصوص الاتفاق الثلاثي الذي تم التوصل
اليه في وقت سابق بين تركيا والسويد
وفنلندا في التوقيت ايضا هذا الامر ياتي
بعد مظاهره
في السوق هولم ليه انصار حزب العمال
الكردستاني تم فيها او طالت الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغانما ادى الى استدعاء السفير
السويدي هنا في انقره الغاء زياره كانت
مرتقبه لوزير الدفاع السويدي الغاء زياره
ثانيه لرئيس البرلمان همم السويدي كل ذلك
ان اردنا ان نسال لماذا فان تركيا تتحدث
هنا عن شروط تتعلق بضروره اتخاذ اجراءات
جده فيما يتعلق بنشاط المنظمات التي
تصنفها ارهابيه وتقصد هنا حزب العمال
الكردستاني بالدرجه الاولى الى جانب تسليم
مطلوبين اليها في النقطه الاخيره هذا
الامر تحديدا قد يرتبط بحسب التحليل
بمساله تتطرق اليها بعض وسائل الاعلام هنا
وهو وجود اطراف هي تريد اثاره هذا همم
رفع التوتر بين كل من تركيا من جهه السويد
وفي لندن من جهه الثانيه ويعزون الامر الى
متطرفين الداعم من لحزب العمال الكردستاني
او قيام انصار من ذات الحزب هذا بهذه
الافعال في محاوله لوقف لوقف مساله تطبيق
هذا الاتفاق وتسليم مطلوبينا الى تركيا
مريم فراح زمان شوقي من انقر شكرا جزيلا
لك